karen jean-pierre se convierte en la
primera secretaria de prensa negra
abiertamente lesbiana en la historia de
la casa blanca la nueva portavoz de joe
biden sustituye a jens aquí que deja la
residencia presidencial para ser
presentadora de la cadena m es en bici y
casi un siglo ha tenido que pasar para
que uno de los cargos más destacados de
la prensa en estados unidos el de
portavoces del presidente también
conocido de manera oficial como
secretario de prensa de la casa blanca
haya podido tener como imagen de
diversidad de una mujer negra el cargo
de secretario de prensa existe desde
1929 bajo la presidencia de herbert
hoover hace ya 93 años la primera mujer
en el cargo fue diddy myers en 1993
durante la presidencia del demócrata
bill clinton de los 35 secretarios de
prensa que ha tenido eeuu un total de 7
han sido mujeres 5 de las cuales han
asumido el cargo desde el año 2017 hace
pues es casi nada y por eso entonces
quiero saludar en ese momento a nuestro
primer invitado el día es robar valència
analista político y miembro te conectas
a punto o hereje gracias a robert por
estar con nosotros en directo americana
de france 24 y le pregunto entonces la
primera portavoz negra porque hasta
ahora es pues lo que representa no la
llegada de jean pierre al portador de la
casa hacer la portavoz de la casa blanca
bueno hasta ahora no sé por qué decirle
hasta ahora esa es una de las grandes
cosas gran hechos que ha ocurrido es
decir que es un hecho es un suceso muy
importante no solamente por las
capacidades que trae karim yampier
porque obviamente ella no es una
desconocida dentro de la política por lo
menos dentro de la política demócrata en
eeuu sino la historia el bagaje que ella
tiene de cómo te lo acabas de mencionar
es la primera mujer negra en ocupar en
este cargo pero no solamente siendo
mujer negra sino también mujer
inmigrante nació en martinica de padres
haitianos sus padres son personas que
han trabajado en digamos en trabajos
regulares no en otra no han trabajado
con el gobierno ella sí logró escalar
estos cargos gubernamentales siendo
también parte de la campaña de john
edwards en la campaña presidencial en el
2004 y así fue ascendiendo también
participó en una organización importante
que es asumido sistema move
es una plataforma para futuros
prospectos políticos en eeuu hasta
llegar al cargo que actualmente tiene es
decir que la sigamos la historia de
karim yampier pues es una historia
fascinante si se quiere ver dentro del
sueño americano que siempre ha sido no
está esta filosofía que se adopta de las
personas que vienen de otros países para
ocupar un cargo tan importante como este
así que ya es el perfecto ejemplo de esa
historia y si sería digamos también como
la segunda después de la vicepresidenta
kamala harris no como toda esa historia
después de que viene una familia de
emigrantes y todo lo que estamos
contando también con jean-pierre pero
también probar ella es la primera mujer
abiertamente homosexual que el mensaje
quiere entregar el gobierno de de jong
vayan a la población
me parece que lo que se está tratando de
hacer aquí es de demostrar la
importancia de la representación
evidentemente jean-pierre tiene digamos
las credenciales para ocupar este cargo
y va a dejar james aquí obviamente como
se dice coloquialmente son zapatos
difíciles de llenar va a tener un
trabajo bastante complicado precisamente
por lo que
representas aquí que fue esta figura
conciliadora
explicaba muy bien temas muy complejos
obviamente más allá de los dimes y
diretes con con los corresponsales de
foxnews es la cadena adversa
ideológicamente a la actual
administración etcétera etcétera pero
indudablemente la figura de elector en
jean pierre es una figura importante por
la representación y no solamente cariño
en piel lo que hemos visto en los
últimos
años o por lo menos en este año de
administración como colocaste mencionar
el hecho de kamala harris siendo una
figura preponderante dentro del partido
también la figura de cristian y brawn de
axxion la primera nominada afroamericana
para la corte suprema es decir lo que
estamos viendo aquí es una
administración que está comprometida en
resaltar la importancia de la
representación de aquellas personas que
no han tenido un papel importante dentro
de la política es evidente que tiene por
delante karen yampier y que se le
destaca no en todo su recorrido y todo
su trabajo para llegar a este cargo tan
importante de ser la portavoz de la casa
blanca
yo creo que para mí uno de los retos más
importantes será el de explicar a
detalle y yo creo que eso es algo que de
alguna manera se le ha hecho difícil a
la administración es resaltar los logros
en medio de una popularidad que sigue en
descenso lo que ha hecho james aquí por
ejemplo es explicar políticas un poco
más complejas y obviamente tendrá que
enfrentarse a la prensa ante preguntas
muy difíciles especialmente con el tema
de ucrania por ejemplo el tema de la
inflación también es otro de los temas
que ya va a tener que enfrentar y
explicar porque como bien lo hemos visto
este rol de la secretaria de prensa o el
secretario de prensa con la prensa pues
de alguna manera lo que más se resalta
no solamente no
el mensaje que se quiere dar si no este
rol antagónico que tiene la secretaria o
el secretario con los medios de
comunicación especialmente medios de
comunicación como lo acaba de mencionar
medios de comunicación que no son
digamos de la misma corriente política
en este caso fox news o
afines estos grupos conservadores estos
medios conservadores y obviamente
presentarse como esa figura
conciliatoria explica las políticas de
presidente yo bailé pero que también
tratará de no sé si evitar ese rol
antagónico dado precisamente esta línea
pierre tiene una historia
de rifirrafes con con próximos
anteriormente incluso llamaba al acta de
edad aena racista o sea que ya estamos
arrancando en ese aspecto con el pie
izquierdo porque yo sé que el fox nos le
va a recriminar esos esos comentarios y
precisamente por la presencia de jordi
pons en las ruedas de prensa obviamente
esto se va a traer a colación y lo que
vamos a seguir viendo precisamente
ese antagonismo que siempre prevalecen
en las redes sociales cuando james aquí
se enfrentaba a firdusi que era el
comentarista o es el reportero
el corresponsal de fox news en la casa
blanca ese va a ser uno de los de los
roles más difíciles y también el de
resaltar el de mejorar la imagen de
iovine de cara a las elecciones del 2022
que según dicen las encuestas
posiblemente los demócratas pierdan
curules de aquí a noviembre y sean los
republicanos que puedan hacerse la
mayoría del senado y posiblemente puedan
recuperar la cámara de representantes
pero todo está obviamente
en entredicho y vamos a ver qué ocurre
en los próximos meses